el ligamento cruzado anterior oa cl por
sus siglas en inglés es uno de los
cuatro ligamentos principales que
conecta el fémur con la tibia el ac l
proporciona estabilidad cuando usted
mueve la rodilla se puede producir un
desgarro del ac l si la articulación de
la rodilla sobre rota o si usted recibe
un golpe directo en la parte delantera
de la rodilla si él hace l se desgarra
por completo el médico le puede
recomendar una cirugía para repararlo
antes del procedimiento recibirá
anestesia raquídea que adormecer a su
cuerpo desde el pecho hacia la parte
inferior o anestesia general la que lo
mantendrá dormido durante el
procedimiento durante el procedimiento
artroscópico el cirujano hará unas
pequeñas incisiones alrededor de la
rodilla a través de las cuales insertará
instrumentos quirúrgicos e incluso una
cámara la cámara transmitirá imágenes a
un monitor de tv las que el cirujano
verá durante el procedimiento
primero el cirujano quitará las partes
restantes del desgarro del ac l de su
rodilla
y luego extraer aparte del tendón
rotuliano para utilizar como injerto u
obtener tejido donante el cirujano
creará puntos de unión para el injerto
mediante la perforación de un pequeño
túnel en el extremo de la tibia y luego
otro en el extremo del fémur el cirujano
ubicará un extremo del injerto del
tendón rotuliano en el túnel tibial
luego levantará el injerto a través de
la articulación de la rodilla y hacia el
túnel femoral para crear un nuevo tendón
hace l por último el cirujano ubicará
pequeños tornillos en los túneles en
cada extremo del nuevo hace el para
mantenerlo en su lugar durante las
próximas 6 a 8 semanas el crecimiento
óseo rellenar a estos túneles y
estabilizar a el injerto
al final del procedimiento el médico
quitará los instrumentos y cerrará las
incisiones este procedimiento
generalmente dura entre dos a dos horas
y media luego del procedimiento usted
pasará a la sala de recuperación durante
dos a tres horas y posteriormente
regresará a su casa probablemente
necesite una rodillera ortopédica y
muletas durante una a cuatro semanas el
tratamiento físico supervisado comenzará
dos o tres días después de la cirugía y
continuará durante seis a diez semanas
después de este tiempo continúe con
tratamiento auto dirigido el tiempo que
sea necesario una cl reconstruido tarda
aproximadamente nueve meses en curarse
completamente debería evitar deportes de
contacto de raqueta y otros deportes que
requieran cambios de dirección rápida
hasta obtener la aprobación de su médico